we ready
i'm totally confident
no we're not supposed to pick like
things that we bring in with us i don't
remember no like what we did i thought
we started off with like a wrench no no
no no oh hey right here oh no i have one
item
wrench it is i'll bring the med kit
because that's what i usually bring
bump funk
i'm going to be a gun boy ah we have a
certain number of pedos i shouldn't say
it that way don't say that
i don't remember what i normally do on
this thing yeah how do i get the map q q
for map right okay oh i normally the
driver do i drive i don't know i maybe
was frequently the captain driver person
but it makes sense do it i can run i've
got it i can drive it
we need to vote we need to vote on who
be the captain road or do a wheel that's
the real question it's i'll leave we'll
we'll do a vote whether we vote or wheel
this is the first vote
okay well should we wheel to see if we
should vote or wheel i can wheel it to
see if we should vote or wheel yeah who
am i looking at right now who's unnamed
and who's dick lickley i'm dick lickley
thank you okay so we i'm this is i'm
skinny boy this is the measure to see
whether or not we're gonna leave
captaining up to voting or a wheel
and we're willing to see if that's a
good idea uh okay
vote to wheel
or
no vote to wheel voting's wheeling
voting all
right oh
all right there will be no vote to
determine whether we should vote
to we pick by wheel so we are we now
we now need to spin a wheel to determine
who is captain does the captain
pilot or does the captain choose what
everyone does
the captain we will decide that with a
wheel yeah we'll wield that when it
comes right all right
all right and we're gonna
captain is
weighed as determined by this wheel
great all right raise wheel what i do is
determined by the next wheel yes unless
you want it to be a vote no we live and
die by the wheel man we live in diablo
way as captain i declare that i have no
power over the wheel all right so
captain steers a wheel the captain
shoots
left gun
shoots right gun
uh manages energy
or captain
looks at
map okay okay
i believe that one's called navigator
navigation i should not be that all
right it's on the wheel okay wheel never
lies wheel never lies i should have put
wait i'm gonna stop the wheel i should
put sleeps because there should be like
a nice one
just sleeps yeah i mean it should be on
the wheel i'm just saying no that's fair
that's fair what's first sleep that's
true all right spinning wheel
okay
captain steer
well i'm glad we went through all that
yep all right it is very amazing
captain do you want to just define our
roles or or like you'll take your own
roles do what you like oh god okay
captain is determined that he wants you
all to just i don't know not blame the
captain for bad content i'll manage the
energy and navigate i guess i'll shoot
front gun or right gun okay bedroom
who's also loading guns the shooters or
the navigator load your own gun you dog
i don't know how to do that so
so you see the torpedo
or as mark calls them the pedos
yeah
you take one from the thing where it
says 25 you pick it up with e and then
you bring it to the whole hole and then
once again
then you can shoot it oh my god wade
what are you doing to us i'm trying to
figure out the controls here i think i'm
getting it have you never there
whoa look at this one in a while okay
you contained
how do i change to the uh other uh type
of camera i know you could do q but
there's another one oh so it's okay for
you not to know the controls
yep uh big space button in the middle
i run our space okay got it
kill the fish
planetary experimentation negation your
captain is going down all right you go
down
so great what else do you want to know
so we need to go deeper is what you're
saying yes all right giant ball giant
ball
i killed ball pop
all right so you got a split path down
into the right
take your pick
they're the same pretty much keep your
head on his twelve got shark come and do
right three o'clock
this jerk
[ __ ] up the other path
you keep playing traveled by i'm getting
motion sick
i'm giving
you guys are doing great you really
showed the hentai who's boss thank you
left or right here right now
gangnam get him he's dead you know what
actually bob i'm taking away your shoe
juice i'm going to give it to wade for
more speed
sure shark
i should have said that oh yep these
guns aren't turning very quick
i was shooting them we got hit once do
we need to repair anything i don't know
what our starting health was 55 is what
we're at you're the captain you tell us
yeah you tell us oh uh yeah the probably
fix something
oh [ __ ] oh there you go we're gonna be
pulled down here yep we're gonna be
pulled down here confirmed captain has
good job captain all right well uh
captain had zero say in that cap zero
save it again what's that sound what's
that
[Applause]
that they're gonna shoot him
you can't shoot him
you got two possible paths cap ones far
right one far left across the gap they
look about the same
all right
our ass
can you stop spinning us i gotta not hit
things okay we're kind of bulky
that's true whoa nailed it
nice yes
straight ahead
we fine it's good
what do bubbles do to us
uh they i think they just contain
enemies sometimes third fish are left
through the tiny gap uh he's fine
that was not
circus
swordfish
all right i hear a leak i'm gonna go fix
it
good thinking good thing we have a shark
straight ahead
found the lead
turns out this has been leaking for a
while captain
all right good work uh dry it get some
towels on it i'm shooting shooting oh
god shooting a lot there's all right
there's got to be another leak somewhere
that ah okay there's a lot of damage
yeah
quickly you got a few holes here
dick literally you might want to take a
breath there's literally nothing i can
do about it oh
yeah you might want to breathe
my face is swollen
the captain's been drowning apparently
yeah
everyone's been drowning there's a bit
of an issue you might want to know yeah
i'm not leaving like fun again it's a
lot nicer in here when i don't see the
damage oh why do you whack me with your
heel stick thanks oh there you go
anymore literally anybody has a wrench
am i the only one with a wrench you are
the only one with the right why am i the
only one with a wrench how do i fix
there we go
look for holes whack them
i'm dying oh god oh god i'm driving i'm
drowning oh
[Applause]
your captain's drowning everyone more
importantly your captain's drowning
ah whatever he didn't help us anyway
[Laughter]
all right well
we made it to the
zeroth level
i think we need to go much deeper i
think we need to go deeper all right we
got a spin for a new captain yeah yeah
new captain yeah sorry wade all right
new captain shall be
john you are our captain okay
i'm excited
the captain's gonna shoot
[Laughter]
oh good good this is
and as your captain i say bob you shoot
and wade you steer
what if we do captain you get to pick
what ship we do too
yeah how many options do we have that
could fit all of us two i mean you could
fit all of them right you could all of
them i don't know if it will allow you
to can we do all of us in the tiny one
that sucks it's just recommended it's a
recommendation
i guess captain gets to choose which
ship all right well there's three ship
options then sir oh god
i might need to put them on the wheel
all right we're loading up the wheels
dude
it says big but captain you can overrule
if you want
i think sounds good ah
all right let's get big okay let it be
known captain has a big ship here we go
see if we had a shield
we've got two guns you're right all
right so
can i bring a wrench or something
i can only pick a range so yeah i only
got a wrench i'm going with medkit again
because that is helpful i just need to
know you guys i'll be the gun fellow i
guess we're going down okay
okay high health is 60 if we're lower
than 60 then we have didn't send or hold
all right duly noted you're not the
captain though but whatever yeah
it's always there i'll see it okay yeah
all right here is lesser people talking
right now sorry captain
captain fair driving sir yeah i shoot
the fish
it's oh my god
shoot those things as well
whoa
all right going to fix that wherever
that was got him
nice don't forget to replenish
ma'am about it might just be a dent
right there isn't it no it's a leak but
it's taken care of ship's all good
captain ship's all good
good good job good job good job keep her
alive keep her afloat or not
i'll promote whoever said that
thank you okay i'm blessed
to know you
oh god
where's the intruder right there he's
huge
you guys need mel mouth mouth mouth
health please i would love some mouth
health to mouth
there you go mom thank you
uh captain wants to know do we have
infinite at this ammo yes yes yes
oh going to fix that 55 out got it on it
kevin
oh god intruder thing whoa found another
one
oh god it's hidden away from your
computer wave your face wade your face
weighed your face
oh god it's walking i should take a
little nap
okay
bad time to dab
all right i guess i'll steer up whatever
all right now
i've never steered in my life captain i
want you to know that down left and
right
ah
up is down i see this is alive
someone please smack that emp or
something oh never mind you guys oh no
we're gonna we're gonna we're getting
we're getting out we're getting it all
right i'm back if you want everybody's
dead we got 58 health so i think we're
good wow
i'm peeling off
captain has said get in the cave we're
in the cave we need to find the dead
somewhere we have a dent somewhere
having permission to find the dent
uh permission granted
we'll find we'll tell you that's in the
captain's room
if he's here
waving my gun
really
captain dent has been found then located
thank you for asking everybody else
you're going to the break right after
this i'm still here
i'm coming out
no no i saw it captain never misses
all right
kill nothing he'll be healed
thank you thank you
oh thank you thank you all money to the
captain come first get first
i don't know i'm a reasonable man
i'm kind of crap there's a skeleton of
some sort what eating meat i don't see
behind us it's invisible i don't
yeah it's invisible i guess it's visible
you're seeing things you're losing it
does anyone need topped off okay
where's the piper into
i'm ten for ten right now is this
treasure chest not open yet i don't know
it doesn't look like it but it wasn't
doing anything for me
oh oh oh permission to have help
uh parisian granny coming whoa skeleton
down to the chest i think you need to
press e to open the chest i see i see
it's still hitting it look a wren hit
him harder
oh
yeah
i switched out to a pipe wrench but i
don't know what that means
i think it does more damage but less all
right careful opening these i picked up
a backpack i'm done ready
okay money
money
okay more money oh money you know how
did you do
any more problems oh what's wrong with
the people lots of money the barrels
hit the barrel
blackened fuel
excuse me it's fun little fun ash
now he's flagon
permission to laugh captain
permission granted laugh ahoy captain
can open okay i hope it goes please uh
please laugh more uh sincerely next time
uh you're all tonight laughing
permissions okay
permission to cry that's what i wanted
permission granted
i think this place is tapped that's
right uh permission to nap after healing
all of you i'm very tired myself
uh permission maybe
baby nappy uh grass ahead
that's good grass it just blocks our
bullets good grass all right we got
swordfish do 4 30.
let's ground the other side of that
and then uh
that's about it cap oh intruder intruder
crab that was good
cabin strange formation do left there's
a strange formation i've never seen kind
of looks like a penis going into a
vagina we definitely gotta check that
out over right head
never mind it's graphical error
graphical error now more looks like a
turd falling out of a butthole it was in
my mind to the best of us don't worry we
all see penises where we want
okay we need help we got a lot of holes
in the bottom right now this is the last
emp hold on blast in the mp oh no we're
good we're good we're going never mind
uh sorry captain how's my bed
we need all hands repairing the can
repair help more than driving
smack smack smack
fixing you do not help with this i know
but i'm healing you or something okay
that's good where's the hole there's
gotta be hole in the bedroom bottom left
bedroom bottom live bedroom incoming
there's another one up here
don't think i need to fix that captain
i'm drowning okay that's okay i fixed it
i'm sorry are we traveling right now uh
we're listing listing listing
i'm never just listing i'm always
closing i think we have to go back up
that's nice
i don't think so
yes
thread the needle left
oh god oh god swordfish all the way
through that channel just keep firing
forward
around i am firing blindly into the
abyss sir abyss is blindly [ __ ] up
keep opening fish coming straight ahead
emergency
there's a strange what there's a time
traveler on our ship oh we have a crab
he's dead i killed oh okay wow good job
team good job team still we are
deeper than we are entering a tombstone
to the right some kind of mausoleum type
thing oh that's scary okay captain uh
enter the dm
shark shark
got him
weak
don't even permission to have a
gratuitous sex with all the alien babes
here
[Applause]
i would love a batter i'm gonna oh
permission to buy a battery cabin
permission batteries
big enough i think we all have
individual money i think oh we have
individuals i have 9.79
and i'm buying this battery let's see if
you buy this if it goes down
battery i still have 9.79 permission to
install battery on the ship captain
permission grant don't look at the
aliens in the eyes they'll seduce you oh
my god do we care about bullet grease or
amlo amlo duplicators
we can't afford them
uh if we can find all their money i
think we can pull our money on one yeah
probably ammo duplicator we could use
more torques
i will contribute
better shoot faster
i don't know
yeah duplicator sounds better anyway
what are you forcing to do that e e just
holding it yeah hold e and you spend i
think we can maybe even help each other
by things
it's not happening you got a whole lot
it's happening look there's a it's full
okay there we go yeah it's filling up it
wasn't working for a second you weren't
here when it wasn't working there we go
you don't even know what that's like
dude permission to install the
ammo duplicate if you can find where it
goes
i apparently am worth negative 79 gold
coins i'm worth negative 101 gold coins
that doesn't feel very good at all
now we're in underwater bank debt
to be paid more next time captain
permission to run from her creditors
whoa there's an up captain what what's
up captain i'm the one who i'm the one
who falls for the jokes
sorry sir captain there's a throne
captain
how do you oh
the grass seaweed my god the princess is
beautiful tonight
my god i thought you said pass are you
going back to smash again oh you haven't
seen the princess
look at her
look idiot i'm on your throne how do you
like that
dude you have a teabag in your throat
you piss off your importance if i heal
the princess if you like me more i will
not do not heal the princess
permission to be very near to the boat
captain wow captain look you got a new
thing on your gun i do yeah you got a
deeper
you'll be happy to know i installed the
battery on your gun so you'll be
shooting twice as fast gavin
wow wait oh
somebody's had guns it's so good being a
captain has perks does cabinet does
are we ready to go captain let's go
punch it punching
that's the opposite of pushing the power
seem
[Laughter]
uh not actually punching not quite
punched
all right wow i should so duplicate it
now both too fast now i gave you more
power i took some speed away from uh
wade didn't seem to do them any good
that's probably well yeah that's
probably for the best i've been on the
goods whoa look at these dupes
whoa we're gonna blast them right in
their faces
that is way fast all right you're
approaching the boss area f shark behind
sharkbite
it's okay watch this
it's the quad con and not the quad
kitten uh kill that thing please thank
you good work
uh yeah blow up the gooses oh intruder
crabs whatever they are scooter killer
where where i don't see no no no we got
him we got him we got him okay good
you're on it
all right yeah it's exactly as it looks
you just need to kill the babies uh and
then down below i think will be the big
one maybe
or maybe god maybe don't have to kill
the bat i don't know yeah i thought we
didn't want to shoot these but i'm
killing everything that moves kill
everything that moves confirmed there's
a lot of babies a lot of babies a lot of
babies confirmed whoa that's a big dude
maybe watch out for the tentacles oh
boy
surrounded oh god incoming babies
you should be on the boat
baby where's it where where is it i
don't know i hear the leak where the
goddamn is this leak
there's a leak ma'am oh here it is
bottom left
are you sure there's a baby on the boat
oh hey yes there is a baby on the boat
babies lots of babies baby's dead all
right
baby's on the boat again
there it is
i can fire three torpedoes at once now
yeah fire
we are getting lots of babies all right
we got fairly a few leaks here
i can handle these guys those launches
like straight up
oh uh baby heading right for us good
work
there you go leaks seem to be handled
for now we have a dent somewhere but
yeah it's fixed we got it
here we go boof
oh wow i gotta aim us down again
it's okay
great power comes at great cost
i'm gonna stay on machine gun and i'm
just gonna take the babies and then
pepper the mama when it's time okay you
guys ready for a boosh
there's a baby coming toward the front
and it's gone
nice they're still a baby but that's not
good
babies babies
many babies many babies babies
thank you thank you this whole time i've
been cooking as well as shooting uh why
don't we go see what mark's eating yeah
what do i have
what did i get
open it and find her
oh
wow it's repairs boost does that mean we
repair faster oh wow
avocado
things
oh it's dark oh yeah all right
bob unfortunately i need to take one of
your gun power
[Music]
no that's okay that's okay under captain
jack we officially got deeper
what do you what are your cats i always
go deeper baby all right uh no uh left
not that way
[Laughter]
incoming
there's a little one uh
no left go left down
oh ah no no my favorite cardinal
direction am i the only one that keeps
saying press q to look outside all the
time
i don't know do you wanna look outside
you can press q yeah
cave do straight down
if you gun it to the cave you might be
able to avoid these guys
oh god that might be just damage there
mr engineering
[Applause]
no i lied okay
all right uh not okay okay
did you guys see the ghost of a crab in
the snail no what i did not
okay okay
[Music]
anymore okay
what a flounder
now he's just an upper
he's spitting look out these bits oh god
whoa
dude spitting and pissing yeah i'm not
the negatives anymore thank you for the
health all for the glory of the captain
i think we'll go
[Applause]
literally moving on its own oh oh god no
yes
you were out
hold on hold on the game is fixing
itself
nothing good nothing good stop our
captain
you permission to make that sound again
ah what the dickens
yeah are things happening in not a way
that makes sense
mean i was in the floor
well that's that's fair captain that's
very fair
i think we might be hallucinating
captain i think this uh place might be
cursed sold for this
medicinal spank you all finally see the
ghost crab yes i think i did
not as crazy as you thought i was all
right
cave clear sir
all right permission great for your
partner
get money
permission granted
oh captain the battery ran out captain
i'm sorry
that jumps out at us right below yeah
all that money on batteries
turns out batteries are temporary
ah this is life oh my god okay swinging
us wildly back and forth makes it really
hard to hit anything not move
you're good turning good if
you haven't asked for the engine to be
off yeah use your horrible idea
use your words not if you're literally
preventing us from killing the thing
that's oh no
that's okay
we didn't kill this one we were shooting
so much in that direction you know
wade you do have fuel
yes so even if i shut off your engine
you can fuel i don't know how to do that
sir
i'm so glad we made you captain
what where this captain
whoa whoa
do something captain oh god let's not
fuel it i don't know what happens when
you're not captain captain
i will
[Music]
my starfish on me kill me kill me or
heal me
i'm not sure kill you
never oh i should oh that's what you
meant by kill you
uh wait hand me wood thanks thanks heal
me yeah thank you prices murdered good
job you're welcome
all right so what was this about wade
being captain no no no it was a slip of
the tongue it was the the mind sulfur
was in my brain
i meant like
captain of the wheel oh god it's gross
naked like the helm at this moment yeah
so wait if you press i believe space you
may notice it didn't work whenever we
didn't have any power i tried space try
now
whoa
oh god where is the league there it is
ah bottom right we're good
all right good job 600 coins hold on i'm
gonna get i'll be right there i'll be
right there i'll be right there
dude next time we get to a store i'm
gonna buy a trampoline
i do not need this right now what this
is a torpedo wait
darling
somewhere i know i know i have
oh god more leaks
there's more leaks sir
does not want to go down helm's been
continue dodging please for the level oh
my god benny leakes
integrity 25.
emp is charged shall we hit it captain
uh no no no wait i think we're good okay
please don't prepare 20 22.
you're drowning bob you're drowning i'm
stick oh god oh
the helmsman smack my ass i wish i could
not
rent a healing ship
some more
uh the grabby hands sir we're driving oh
god
i was trying to come after you everyone
oh
god didn't wish someone knew how to turn
the engine off
oh permission to turn engine off turning
engine off
but turning yeah
die captain i have what health i'm
drowning
oh god it's gross and it's on the helm
and it pooped getting them getting them
getting them getting them getting out of
oxygen there's less than i do
getting him wait heal me back to life
[Applause]
is
oh
[Music]
but much better under your leadership
captain
soldiers
[Music]
permission to rest in peace
[Music]
you